nicolas vidal heureux de vous retrouver
en ce jeudi matin dans la matinale de
rtl france à l'heure nicolas pourquoi
selon vous l'état régalien est-il
défaillant bonjour cher olivier oui
l'état régalien est en train de
s'effondrer chaque jour un peu plus
et ce n'est pas la crise sanitaire bien
entendu qui va tester du contraire
rappelez-vous lionel jospin qui nous
disait l'état ne peut pas tout à la fin
des années 90 quelques exemples des
affrontements violents à dijon entre les
mains de la communauté tchétchène et
magrets vie l'été dernier réglée par un
imam pas par la préfecture mais pour
animal apeuré autorités judiciaires
ensuite que récemment la faire d'idée le
maire vous savez ce prof de philo et qui
a créé un cri d'alerté une emprise
communautaire attrapé a été pris à parti
menacé qui a même dit lui même qui
pourrait quitter l'enseignement ensuite
la sphère du squat à toulouse a rappelé
vous hollande 88 ans les squatteurs qui
était chez lui depuis très longtemps qui
ont cédé les squatteurs à la
mobilisation citoyenne a pris plusieurs
jours et ensuite a eu la célèbre affaire
tristement célèbre affaire milla vous
savez cette jeune fille qui a critiqué
l'islam sur une sur une vidéo sur tik
tok
elle était bonne que reese est enfermée
chez elle harcelés menacés obligé de
changer d'établissement à deux reprises
finalement c'est extrêmement intéressant
d'ailleurs allé à like
elle a quitté le lycée militaire ou
électriques dernièrement et il le
communiqué disait notamment du ministère
des armées
milla n'avait pas été à ce qu il a été
proposé à ses parents que poursuivre
pour un temps son enseignement à
distance dans un lieu sûr le temps de
l'apaisement de la situation sécuritaire
voilà qu'est ce que cela nous apprend
ces trois-quatre exemple ça nous apprend
qu'un état finalement le détail
s'abstient d'intervenir pour maintenir
l'ordre et amener le rétablir pardon la
paix civile
c'est comme une corolle des casques
bleus notamment à toulouse pour la faire
roulante des squatteurs en fait détail
ne fait que proposer y relocaliser
victimes ou les éloigne du danger il a
rendu les ans souvent ils communiquent
mais en fait il refuse l'état régalien
de rétablir l'ordre et ce sont les
protagonistes 1 qui met un terme aux
affrontements en prenant compte bien
entendu des rapports de forces en
présence enfin l'état de droit qui
s'amenuisent de plus en plus il appela
son règlement de comptes
et il laisse surtout olivier la
progression des territoires perdus de la
république
ce qui est intéressant et passionnant
est effrayant c'est la perte de
confiance totale avec la population et
c'est surtout l'affirmation de
l'impuissance publique ce qui est
absolument dévastateur pourtant nicolas
la france est première aux dépenses
publiques dans l' ocde l etat est très
présent est fortement mise à
contribution pour la dépense publique
non oui vous l'avez dit rien c'est 741
milliards dette sociale en 2018
imaginez-vous 7 et 31% du pipe en 2019
c'est 32% du pile c'est ça que ce
champion du monde la france est la
championne du monde des pays de l'osce
est dû à ce niveau de dépense et on
imagine que pour 2020 avec crise
sanitaire ça va encore monter ça va
casser le plafond qu'est ce que c'est
que vous sur vos prestations sociales et
modernisation chômage chômage partiel
bien entendu rsa allocations familiales
apl de sécurité sociale retraites cmu à
elbeuf
alors pourquoi y'a trois points à 7
aides sociales massives il ya cette
madone social propre à la france est un
choix de société bien entendu l'état
providence c'est une politique sociale
extrêmement importante et plus aussi
fort vieillissement la population en
france
deuxième point extrêmement important et
j'y reviendrai si l'obligation d'être
social pour les tard parce que pour
faire face finalement conséquence yeux
désastre et aux excès de la
mondialisation parce qu'il est
impossible de laisser les perdants cette
mondialisation
vous savez au bord du chemin à la phrase
de bruno le maire donc ces aides
sociales massives
c'est un amortisseur social extrêmement
important pour éviter le chaos
et puis non
point qu'un peu plus moins méconnu c'est
les fraudes aux prestations sociales
dénoncé par le juge charles prat
alors les chiffres y saut vertigineux
charles prat
il dénonce près de 5 en demi heure 50
milliards entendez bien de fraude aux
prestations sociales
mais la réalité la plus criants de ces
trois points c'est l'effet boomerang
gens passent souvent seul en tête de la
mondialisation épousé depuis mitterrand
depuis 83 kg paupérisée bien entendu une
majorité des français et notamment la
classe moyenne délocalisations
licenciements d'extrusion d'emploi
concurrence déloyale et j'en fasse est
cependant cependant l'état social vous
savez c'est le pire cauchemar des néo
libéraux ou des libéraux résisté le
terme qu'il vous conviendra on entend
souvent que la france est dans une haie
pas un pays libéral parce qu'elle aide
extrêmement beaucoup d'ailleurs pierre
moscovici le chantre de l'austérité le
grand mamamouchi la cour des comptes
veut continuer à sabrer dans les
dépenses publiques c'est un chaos à
venir au vu de la crise sanitaire chez
olivier et sur le plan économique
nicolas quel constat faites vous du rôle
de l'état alors les tailles des devenu
le cost killer aux services du néo lève
néolibéralisme tout puissant depuis 86
la france et la privatiser à touba
totalement ou partiellement
havas tf1 suez des banques paribas
société générale france télécom thompson
air france ou et rameute ashton suit
manuel macro ça continue et un renault
mdj edf et le fameux le fameux projet et
recule de la branche nucléaire
il ya aussi la privatisation vous l'avez
la communauté des retraites qu'ils
encourent et la privation tout bonnement
du système de santé est également en le
sait depuis quelques semaines la
privatisation de l'action publique
rappelez-vous les cabinets de conseils
mackenzie et consorts qui finalement
donne une idée de la situation sanitaire
et tout ça et tout ça est insufflée par
une politique de
bénédiction de l'union européenne avec
lego paix les grandes orientations de
politique économique et aussi le plan de
relance signé en juillet 2020 finalement
ce que ce tout en tout ça c'est le
renoncement de nos élites à la nation et
aux obligations supérieur que confère
depuis 30 ans olivier les tailles de
gouverne de plus on fait des tags le
fait que réformer sous l'oeil
concupiscent l'union européenne et il ya
toujours une sas une notion sa vie de
sacrifice de douleurs d'austérité donc à
venir on va y avoir des réformes
brutales vous savez on le sait tous
celle des retraites de l'assurance
chômage contre les intérêts des français
finalement on essaie nos élites depuis
30 ans essaye de dissoudre la france
dans la mondialisation et le réformateur
est devenu la figure parfaite et un
conflit du marché roi alors que fois que
son constat chez encore qu'on leur
l'état régalien revient la phase de
consultation populaire quand cette
politique néolibérale il revient l'état
dans les manifs maintien de l'ordre
répression garde à vue on va en reparler
gilet jaune réforme des retraites
pompiers soignants finalement cher
olivier le néolibéralisme s'accommode
très mal de la démocratie et son pire
ennemi c'est l'état nation merci nicolas
nicolas vidal votre édito que l'on peut
retrouver sur tous les comptes
rt sur les réseaux sociaux